foreign
produced in 2002 and recorded on this
floppy disk is one of the most
destructive viruses when 9x cih it's
also called Chernobyl
it is affected up to 60 million PCS
around the world this virus was
destroying data on hard drives but not
only this it could damage the data on
the BIOS chips that is physically
destroy the computer so that it no
longer even switched on
when 9x cih created an epidemic
but how
impossible
it was created by the some
subverification platform but more about
some sub innovate
the viruses were refined in the unwieldy
IBM
B Mainframe computer they were created
in 1961 within the walls of bell
Laboratories
Bell Labs is a remarkable institution
founded in the 20th century by the
creator of the telephone Alexander Bell
nine Nobel laureates in various Fields
have grown up within the walls of bell
Labs some call it an idea Factory
some call it an organization that
invented our present ladies and
gentlemen Bell Laboratories invites you
to hear the light of that which relates
to the online jungle Bell Labs created
the programming languages C and C plus
plus as well as the Unix operating
system which would later give rise to
Linux in one single largest building
there were probably 4 000 people of whom
about two thousand were probably phds in
various forms of science physics
chemistry materials and then on the call
up the software in mathematics and the
relatively new field of computer science
at that point large number of really
really excellent people and the
environment was you can do anything you
want well you get the idea and it was in
this atmosphere in 1961 that the
development team created the Darwin game
Malcolm McIlroy Victor visotsky Robert
Morris but remember this name especially
programmers were inspired by the theory
of self-reproducing automata which was
created in the 50s by the brilliant
mathematician and Pioneer of cybernetics
John Von Neumann in developing this
Theory Newman relied on the structure of
the nervous system and the reproduction
methods of human cells
in fact this is a thought experiment
considering the possibility of the
existence of a mechanical organism for
example computer code that could damage
machines create its own copies and
infect new machines in the same way as a
biological virus does
under the influence of these ideas at
midnight in Bell Labs laboratory Darwin
appeared but not for the sake of a
bright future just for fun this is how
the developers described the rules of
the game Darwin is a game played by two
or more people each player devises a
program or programs the programs of any
one player constitute a species all the
players programs are simultaneously in a
section of core known as the arena
whichever program is currently in
control tries a to replicate itself in
an unoccupied part of the arena and B as
a means to this end to destroy members
of other species by attacking their
vulnerable locations the essence of the
game was succinctly described by a
well-known researcher of the online
jungle Stephen Levy these beasts were
the digital Warriors in a gladiatorial
game called Darwin
foreign
ly there are no images of the original
Darwin left but this is what the later
version for Mac looked like after each
round the Gladiators the predecessors of
computer viruses imprisoned in the arena
were erased everything was kept as a
secret it was only 10 years later that
McIlroy Morris and vasotsky first spoke
about Darwin in a letter to an academic
journal in this letter describing the
strategies of their self-replicating
Gladiator programs the authors used the
word virus for the first time but at
this point only tentatively writing the
term in quotation marks the programmers
also described how the experiment came
to an end they played only a few rounds
until a couple of weeks later Robert
Morris invented a killer program soon
the information about the game was
published publicly and programmers
started playing Darwin in the early 80s
an improved version of Darwin was
released core War core war made it
possible to create even more
sophisticated Gladiators than had been
possible in Darwin although the Creator
postulated that core War organisms would
not be able to survive outside of the
Arena nonetheless aboard computer
scientists students and even school
children continued to come up with a
number of information organisms that
were able to survive outside of the
confines of the game but at this point
they were yet to cause serious harm
often such viruses contained a silly
joke or message that would intrusively
pop up on the user's screen it was at
this time that the emergence of hacker
culture began so far there was nothing
more to this than Lively curiosity and
childishness certainly nothing dangerous
the central processing unit at Clemson
is an IBM 370 3033 our CPU is equipped
with eight megabytes of Mainframe
storage it was more science fiction
Racers that were thinking about the
danger of viruses than anyone else or
filmmakers for example the Cults film
Tron the first film where CGI was used
was based on the Darwin game concept
what kind of program is he he's not any
kind of program Sark he's a user
first he was the loudest of them all to
draw attention to the danger of these
self-produced programs which did not yet
have a clear definition was Fred Cohen
Cohen now a doctor of Sciences devoted
his working life to computer security in
November 1983 it was still a graduate
student at the University of South
Carolina like the creators of Darwin
Cohen was familiar with the work of Von
Neumann and asked the question what if
programs could be embedded in other
programs and take control of them in the
same way as parasites attached to a host
but this thought wasn't new the
uniqueness of Cohen's contribution was
that he was the first to realize the
potential dangers of such programs Cohen
in his dissertation gave the first
definition of a computer virus and this
definition like the name came into
circulation for his research Cohen wrote
a virus in one evening 200 lines in the
programming language C Cohen was allowed
to run this virus on the Unix
environment of the vax 11750 computer at
their University and became the first
computer scientist who made a
scientifically controlled release of a
predatory information organism into the
wild Curran was shocked by the speed at
which the virus spread a week later he
demonstrated his experiments to fellow
students and they hardly knew what they
were looking at with Cohen understood
that even if he stopped working on the
problem of viruses it would not simply
evaporate and despite the obstacles he
continued his work reaching conclusions
that not everyone liked for example he
concluded that it was impossible to
create a perfect antivirus it will still
be malware capable of bypassing the
protection and he predicted the first
viral pandemic was on the horizon in the
near future and he was absolutely right
despite the constant development of new
technologies the internet is still a
modern day jungle unlike real jungles
however the internet is filled with
users being hunted for their data and
money who are the predators online
fraudsters and money launderers just
like our ancestors did we need to use
special tools to confront the dangers of
the internet
take for example an efficient
verification provider such as some sub
which can minimize the amount of
fraudulent activity and help your
company be brave in the wilderness some
sub is an all-in-one verification
platform that secures every step of the
customer Journey some sub Services can
be used by Banks fintech the gambling
industry and many other businesses with
some subs verification Solutions you can
customize all your onboarding procedures
welcome more customers worldwide speed
up onboarding reduce costs and steer
clear of digital fraud Samsung achieves
the highest conversion rates in the
industry while verifying users in less
than 50 seconds on average
if you want to learn more about the
company check out the link in the
description and get the demo today
the authors of the first IBM PC virus
brain from which began the first mass
computer epidemic didn't try to hide
furthermore their name and address was
known by everyone who had the misfortune
of their IBM being infected here it is
amjad Alvi was 18 years old when he
opened his computer shop brain in the
suburbs of the Pakistani City Lahore
later his brother joined the business
they were both self-taught programmers
at first the brothers simply repaired
PCS and then they began to create their
own specialized software namely medical
we were experimenting few things one
thing that indoors we can have something
multitasking kind of thing and the
second thing to explore security holes
of that of the operating system when we
explored that the security issues of the
doors and realized that it is quite
vulnerable to to the piece of codes kind
of piece of code we wrote back then so
that was the motivation that's how brain
appeared described by its creators as a
friendly virus for tracking pirated
copies of the olvi brothers software
however not everything went according to
plan and this friendly virus created the
first epidemic and so commenced the era
of viruses on MS-DOS Microsoft Disk
Operating System a popular operating
system in the 80s and until the mid-90s
which preceded The Familiar graphical
user interfaces of today's systems that
virus was not destructive and it was not
made to destroy any data and it was very
friendly virus it only detects if the
space is available in floppy it only
goes then into that particular floppy
brain is a boot sector virus that is
it's spread through infected floppy
disks if we're to explain the idea
simply then a virus was stored on the
floppy disk along with the brothers's
software the same self-replicating
program that infected the computer of an
unauthorized user for example it slowed
down the the machine in rare cases it
took data from the floppy disk brain
didn't touch the hard drive those who
noticed the Slowdown started looking for
the cause and came across this message
with contacts in order to cure the
computer it was necessary to ring the
number provided so the brothers sort of
caught Pirates red-handed according to
various sources brain managed to infect
from 20 000 to 250 000 PCS worldwide the
amount of damage is unknown
one more time this is without internet
just on floppy disks
the virus crossed the ocean and ended up
in the computer classrooms of the
largest universities in the United
States Pennsylvania Delaware Washington
but how did this even become possible
after all the brothers hid the virus on
floppy disks with specialized medical
software useless to an ordinary user but
this turned out to not be the case the
brothers went further in their
experiments to punish Pirates Time
magazine in 88 revealed all the details
the brain Computer Services of the Alvey
brothers sold floppy disks with
proprietary software for example
lotus123 and wordstar for just one
dollars and fifty cents a piece which in
the United States could cost several
hundred dollars dozens of tourists
stopped by the brother's store and
bought discs for their home computers
and on these discs with pirated versions
of programs by the way it was also brain
just like that of course an unsuspecting
user would lend a floppy disk to a
friend or colleague and the virus would
spread
the Alvey Brothers said they stopped
selling infected floppy disks in 1987.
after they were satisfied that they had
taught the Pirates a lesson well or
maybe after getting tired of angry calls
from all over the world they wrote that
they even had to turn off the phone the
brain virus epidemic launched a major
revolution in the I.T sector McAfee and
others have developed new
countermeasures called vaccines and
antiviral programs that detect and
neutralize viral infections John
McCarthy made money on the fight against
Brain and even complemented the
self-taught programmers calling the
virus elegant and admiring the way it
was made
[Music]
just as we've become totally dependent
on our computers they're being stalked
by saboteurs saboteurs who create
computer viruses 1988 people are all
head up about viruses they're in the
news they're on the cover of Time
Magazine Society thought that viruses
had to be harmful to kill computers and
to raise data but technical enthusiasts
understood that this was not necessary
characteristics of a virus at all
usually teenagers early 20s
were basically hobbyist programmers they
did this because they felt like they
wanted to make something a lot of these
were tested their own skills for example
for some it was a challenge to
themselves to stay ahead of the curve
for some it was a way of causing
harmless mischief
thank you for watching happy Halloween
for example the casino virus forced you
to gamble on your data to win against
the virus was impossible at the end your
computer would shut down either way for
some the challenge was to create a virus
that can quickly and imperceptibly cover
the widest possible network of computers
why you ask to put anti-virus
manufacturers in their place and show
how insignificant their products are
foreign
it was a special time
anyway someone eventually got carried
away with a bold idea of teaching a
lesson to smug anti-virus manufacturers
a graduate student at Cornell University
started skipping lectures on computer
science and instead reflected on the
invisible software that endlessly
spreads across the universal computers
and at the same time is able to protect
itself from those who want to erase it
this graduate student Robert knew that
the author of this program would try to
track him down so he launched his virus
from a computer at another University
MIT on the evening of November the 2nd
1988 he released the first Network worm
the virus picked up passwords to various
Services of network users clogged their
Ram with useless processes that branched
every three seconds in the next 24 hours
the worm affected about 6 000 computers
of the 60 000 connected to the arpanet
network
generally speaking this was a prototype
of the internet created by the Pentagon
web before web
week later all traffic was congested
with the worm the media published
panicked headlines it arrived at MIT in
the middle of the night the students
were safe their computers weren't there
were different ideas about how to stop
the virus Mark I can students and
part-time virus Hunter once we had it
stopped we were able to take it apart
sort of like dissect it and tear it
apart piece by piece this worm clogged
the system of thousands of computers but
apparently did no damage it's benign
it's not malicious it attempts to do no
damage besides propagate itself and
that's why I think it's a warning the
suspect somewhere a dark genius
meanwhile Robert called his friends and
confessed I think I've really [ __ ] up
I started a virus and it isn't working
at all the way it's supposed to he could
not bring himself to come clean and
asked his friend from Harvard to send an
anonymous message over the Internet it
contained an apology and instructions on
how to beat the worm however because the
network was so overloaded no one
received the message the worm didn't
destroy anything but it slowed
everything down so much that out of
desperation many simply turned off their
computers for a week the most radical
even destroyed their computers
now get ready for a Twist Robert was
quickly found November the 5th 1988 this
date marked not only the first mention
of the internet in the New York Times
but also probably the first
de-anonymization
one of the creators of Darwin Robert
Morris senior was not best pleased by
his son's unsuccessful developments he
spoke about his son's work with
restraint describing it as the work of a
board graduate student ah those board
programmers the exact damage caused by
the Morris worm was difficult to
quantify but estimates started at a
hundred thousand dollars and soared into
the millions the story of the worm
exploded on the media and Robert was the
first person in U.S history to be
indicted under the newly defined
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act the jury
found him guilty and he was given three
years of probation 400 hours of
community service and a fine of ten
thousand and fifty dollars and payment
for the costs of his supervision however
he went on to do well even working at
mic so that's how in one generation from
Morris senior to Morris Jr computer
viruses took on a modern form
what began as a bit of fun for nerds had
started to turn into a weapon that is
with the help of intellectual courage
and a bit of vanity viruses were
increasingly showing their dark side
the next Global epidemic of computer
viruses caused an estimated 1.3 billion
dollars of damage not bad for typing a
couple of numbers for many newcomers PC
stands for pain and confusion the virus
first became active on April 26 1999. on
the anniversary of the Chernobyl
accident on half a million computers
around the world with Windows 95 and 98
operating systems information on hard
drives was destroyed the virus instantly
acquired the nickname Chernobyl but that
wasn't all the damage Chernobyl could do
more than just destroy the data it could
overwrite the BIOS that is the usual way
to tackle a virus is to overwrite
Windows but if your bios is down then
what should you do not everyone knew how
to reflash the BIOS back then and even
fewer know now there were computers on
which it was basically impossible to do
this so the machine could only be thrown
out or the motherboard could be changed
to put it literally the computer would
physically die
it transpired that the virus escaped
almost a year before day x it patiently
waited in the wings and moving unnoticed
from computer to computer it's not easy
to construct the entire chronology of
events but we'll try to piece it
together from old news stories let's
begin our story in April of 1998 Taiwan
at that time student Chen inghao had
already been punished for developing a
virus that infected the tatong
university database in Taiwan at the
time the virus was known as cih by the
initials of a hacker according to one
version of offense Chen created the
virus to make appoints to sellers of
antivirus programs that proved useless
in the fight against viruses on
University computers Chen who was a
senior at the time was given a demerit
but not expelled he graduated from
University and went on to serve in the
Army meanwhile the virus began to travel
the world it was often distributed
through gaming Services the origin
systems developers website contained an
infected file that linked to their
popular space flight simulator Wing
Commander at first the virus wasn't
taken seriously but on April 26th the
bomb exploded and everyone was terrified
outbreaks of the virus were reported
from all over the world four days later
the name of the epidemics culprit became
known Chen's alma mater didn't hesitate
to tell on her former student
the military quickly found changing how
among their ranks and apparently had an
educational conversation with him but
there was nothing more to be done no one
brought charges against him and besides
there was no corresponding law under
which to convict him as it turned out
the Creator had no connection to the
Chernobyl accident at all it was just a
coincidence that on this day in 98 Chen
finished working on the virus and gave
it one year to conquer the world
although he didn't expect it to be that
effective the Chernobyl virus can still
be found its outer shell has changed a
little but the code still works exactly
as it did on April 26th we just found a
version of this ancient virus on the
internet let's take a look at how it
works
the cih file is disguised as a paint
file let's click on it
now we wait
a few minutes have passed and there's
been no response at all the computer has
stopped responding to clicks of the
mouse
it's fruitless to try an open Task
Manager everything's just Frozen we've
tried reboot and click reset
we get stuck on this screen
we're trying to reboot again
[Music]
again we don't get further than this
screen we reload again and we see the
message disk boot failure insert system
disk and press enter
so we've damaged the system disk the
computer has lost the path to the drive
with the operating system is located
Chernobyl became the next stage of the
evolution of viruses no virus before it
had so decisively crossed the line
between the virtual world and the
present by the beginning of the
naughties no one had any doubts about
the destructive potential of computer
viruses the internet seems to be a safe
space Electronics have become integrated
in the state's critical infrastructure
and the internet was becoming a
battlefield this new era of warfare has
already begun
the first attack using a computer virus
called stuxnet was launched several
years ago against an Iranian nuclear
facility did the next Pearl Harbor that
we confront could very well be a Cyber
attack the biggest change over the years
has been the motives of virus rightes
viruses have not only been militarized
but also criminalized for the sake of
profit and let's not forget the addition
of social engineering well that's the
story brilliant ideas can be dangerous
right dive into the world of the online
jungle with some sub until the next
story
[Music]
thank you